so far we talked about uh different
variants of sat
uh in in particular we also talked about
um vans of sat with alternative
quantifiers so define polynomial time
hierarchy
very important related notion of sat
is counting satisfying assignments and
that's what we're going to talk
about next the problem is called
sharp sat and it's defined as follows
you're given an input formula
maybe three cnf maybe circuit
phi on n variables and you want to
output the actual
number of all satisfying assignments for
the formula phi
which can be expressed as this
exponential summation where you
try all possible boolean assignments and
evaluate formula five
on each and count one for each
satisfying assignment
and zero for unsatisfying one
obviously sharp shot is more difficult
than sat
and in particular it's not hard to see
it's a triviality that np
is contained in peel the sharp sides
if you can count then you can decide if
the formula satisfiable or not
what is much more surprising is that
if you allow yourself oracle access to
sharp sat
not only can you solve np but you can
solve
any problem in polynomial time hierarchy
as well so you can eliminate
alternating quantifiers existential
universal
if you have access to algorithm for
counting satisfying assignments
and that's a famous result due to toda
from around 91
where he showed that polynomial time
hierarchy is contained in
p to the sharpshot not a very
interesting
corollary of this result is that
if i have a
fairly good algorithm for sharpshot if
we can count satisfying assignments
in some sub-exponential time like to the
end of the
epsilon for some tiny epsilon then by
toda's result
here we can put polynomial time heart
every problem in the polynomial time
hierarchy also in sub-exponential time
because
everything in polynomial time hierarchy
is polynomial time reducible to sharp
sat
polynomial time reduction can blow up
the input size only polynomially
and this polynomial blob is going to be
eaten by
sub-exponential time till the end of a
little one time
so of course it's unlikely and we'll
talk about that
more a bit later that sat or even
less likely sharpshot has a
sub-exponential time algorithm
but it's still conceptually very
interesting that
before uh in our early proof where we
showed that
if you have a polynomial time algorithm
then you can collapse polynomial time
hierarchy to polynomial time
that proof if you think about it does
not show
um a generalized version where instead
of assuming that site is important of
time you assume that sat is in
sub-exponential time
and you want to conclude that say
polynomial time hierarchy is in
sub-exponential time
even for sigma 2 we cannot improve
and get sub-exponential time algorithm
for a sigma-2 problem
because if you remember you have this
composition
of the run times of your sat algorithm
and if the runtime of the set algorithm
was polynomial then polynomial composed
with the power long it was still
polynomial so it's still good
that's how you get this result here but
if your
runtime of the sat algorithm is
sub-exponential
composing sub-exponential with
sub-exponential
does not give you anything nice
okay so to this result does give you
something nice
but you need to strengthen your
assumption from
sad being in parliament or time to sharp
sad
being non-trivial like sub-exponential
time or better
another interesting thing is that you
only need
black box access to this sharpshot
algorithm as opposed to
our earlier proof collapsing the
following all time hierarchy under the
assumption of status and p
where we needed white box uh we needed a
source code for the set algorithm
to carry out that proof argument
so i'm not going to prove to you this a
fantastic result due to toda
but i will talk about an ingredient in
this proof
which is interesting in its own right
because it talks about another
very important problem of variant of
satisfiability
so-called unique sat so unique sat
is a problem to distinguish between
formulas which are unsatisfiable and
formulas which have exactly
one satisfying assignment so your input
is promised to be of two kinds
either the number of satisfying
assignments is one or the number of rank
assignments is zero
and you want to tell which
obviously unique sub is reducible to sat
if i have a sat algorithm then i can
answer unique sat
questions easily if formula is uniquely
satisfiable and because satisfiable if
it's not satisfiable then it's still not
satisfiable
so the reduction here is very trivial
just the identity function
what is much more interesting is kind of
the other direction
where if you know how to solve unique
sat
then you can solve general sat as well
and that's somewhat surprising it was
surprising at the time
when this result was proved by valentin
vazirani
basically they've shown that
satisfiability
is probabilistically polynomial time
reducible
to the problem of unique sat so here rp
stands for randomized polynomial time
basically it's a tuning machine which is
allowed to flip random coins
and unlike the deterministic machine it
will now have some probability
of getting the correct answer and some
probability of making
a mistake and it's an rp machine if it's
probability of making a mistake is
relatively small is bounded by say less
than 10
so let me explain to you how does sat
reduce to unique start in a randomized
way
that's this famous result due to
valentine's irani from
around 1986 and
the way i will state this result is
a randomized transformation that will
take an input formula phi
again maybe phi is a 3cnf and will
output
a list of new formulas psi 1
psi n all of them on the same
set of n variables as phi
but if i was a 3 c and f
psi 1 psi n will no longer be
three cnfs necessarily you'll see why in
a moment
but the property of this randomized
transformation mapping
a single formula phi to this small list
of
n formulas psi sub 1 to psi sub n
is the following if the original formula
phi
was not satisfiable then each of the
produced formulas
psi sub i will not be satisfiable
as well on the other hand if the formula
phi
was satisfiable then with some
non-trivial constant probability
say at least one over eight this
randomized
procedure will produce a list such that
at least one formula on that list at
least some sub
i will be uniquely satisfiable it will
have exactly one satisfying assignment
so it's not hard to see that if i have
such a
randomized polynomial time algorithm and
i do have it
it transforms formulas to list of
formulas
then if you give me an algorithm for
solving unique sat
using this transformation and that
algorithm for unique sub i can also
solve sat
how give me an instance of sat i will
perform my
reduction given by this procedure i will
compute the list
of formulas using randomness and then i
will run my unique site algorithm on
each one
of the formulas in the list if on at
least one of them it answers yes
then i will say accept formula five is
satisfiable
and if my unique set algorithm will
answer no on all of the formulas
then i will say no my original formula
phi is not satisfiable
and you should see the correctness of
this algorithm that i described
it's immediate from the definition of
the reduction in violent vaginas
procedure
if formula satisfiable all formulas psi
sub i will be unsatisfiable
so unique site algorithm will must
answer no no no no for each one of them
on the other hand if the formula five
was satisfiable then with
decent probability at least one of the
formulas on the list will satisfy the
unique sat promise that it has exactly
one satisfying assignment so the unix
algorithm must answer yes
and so i will get the answer yes in this
case with probability at least one over
eight
and it's the usual thing you can boost
the probability of success by doing some
repetitions and
taking majorities and so forth okay so
you'll get a randomized algorithm for
sat
if unique sat is in probabilistic or
deterministic
uh pollen of time for example so in this
sense unique sat is like very difficult
it's
as hard as general sat if you can solve
unique sat
efficiently then you can also solve
channels that
efficiently but now you have to use
randomness and it's open problem
uh whether you can to randomize this
construction and reduce the amount of
randomness
needed it seems to be very difficult to
do so
okay but let's get back to the reduction
in valence was uranus result
so i want to give you a proof idea of
how you built this
list of formulas psi sub 1 to psi sub n
from a given formula phi that you start
with
so what you're going to do is use
randomness
by creating a random xor constraint
as follows you pick it random as subset
of
indices between 1 and m set capital s
and you pick a random bit
b from 0 1 and then you define the
following
xor constraint h sub s comma b
on x1 through xn to be saying that
if you look at the parity of the bits x
i
indexed by the set s then their parity
is equal to b
okay so it's a random parity constraint
on a
set of variables x1 for xn so
how does it help to introduce this
random parity constraints well
let's think suppose i have formula phi
on n variables
which has some number capital m
satisfying assignments
let's assume that m is positive so
formula phi is actually satisfiable
then if i take a random constraint
h sub s comma b
and put the conjunction of phi and this
constraint
getting a new formula
the number of satisfying assignments in
this new formula phi
conjuncted with h comma h sub s comma b
intuitively will reduce by a factor of
two why because a random parity
constraint
is likely to kill off or expect it to
kill off for sure
half of the assignments in the formula
five so
if you look at any assignment that was
satisfying formula five
that assignment will satisfy a random
pair to constrain
h of x1 through xn with probability
exactly one-half
okay that's not very difficult to see
thinking about random periods
so we expect to half the number of
satisfying assignments in the formula
five
after conjuncting phi with one
random constraint now if you repeat it a
few times
then you reduce by a factor of two in
expectation each time
and so intuitively if you do this
random parity constraint addition about
log of capital m times where m remember
was the number of satisfying assignments
and put phi conjunct with this bunch of
random parity constraints then you will
you expect
to reduce the number of satisfying
assignments if i two to one
okay of course all of this is in
expectation
and we want to produce a random
formulas size of one size of t
such that with non-trivial relatively
high probability like one over eight
one of them is uniquely satisfiable if
phi
is satisfiable so how do we go from
expectation to
something that happens with reasonably
high probability
well um this cons this reduction from
expectation to the high probability
follows from the properties of this
random parity constraints uh the
property being two-wise independence
and if you've seen hash functions before
then you would recognize that basically
these h's are random hash functions
uh whose range is one bit and if you
take k of them then you'll have a
universal hash function whose range is
k bits and then you just need to figure
out what the right range k
is so that you isolate
exactly one satisfying assignment of the
formula phi
that seems to be a big problem right
because we don't know
what is the number of satisfying
assignment of a formula phi
so we don't know how how many this
random
xor constraints to take however
it's enough to get an approximate
value k such that
the actual number of satisfying
assignments for the formula
phi is between to the k minus 2
and to the k minus 1. so if i know the
sharp side of phi to within a factor of
two roughly speaking
then that's enough why is it good
well there are only n possible factors
of
two to approximate the number of
satisfying assignments for five because
the number of satisfying assignments of
phi
is some number but between
0 and 2 to the n so the number of powers
of 2
is like 2 0 to the 1 to the 2 and so
forth to the m so i only like
about n possibilities for my power
k here and i don't know which k to use
but there are not so many of them so i
will try them all
okay and that's how i get the list so i
try
each value of k between two and n plus
one say
and i will form using randomness and do
it independently for different
size i form psi sub k by taking my
original phi
and picking k independent random parity
constraints
this hash functions i mentioned
independently each one and put the new
formula
phi and conjunction of this parity
constraints
and i do it for case ranging
from 2 to the n plus 1 so i get a list
of n
formulas in the end
okay and i will not be given the
computation here
it's some simple calculations based on
the
paris independence that allows you to
argue that this
process succeeds with probabilities at
least one over eight
meaning that if i built the list of this
psi sub k formulas like i described
then a formula phi was satisfiable and
with probability at least one over eight
for the correct choice of k which gives
me the right approximation
here i will get unique satisfying
assignment isolated
by restricting with this k random parity
constraints
okay so as i mentioned this result
was part of todd's proof but it's also
very exciting result on its own it
allows you to
basically focus on the hardest case of
satisfiability
which is unique satisfiability so you
can assume when you design your
site algorithm that your formula say
without also generality is uniquely
satisfiable and try to
analyze your site algorithm for that
special case
and by the valiant wizarding reduction
is as general as needs
as needs to be
great so what else can we say about
sharp sat
well sharpshot is a very interesting
problem on the one hand it's very hard
as we saw on the other hand it does have
some kind of notion of efficient
probability
associated with it so sharps up
can be shown to have so-called
interactive
proofs so let me talk about interactive
proofs
for a moment
as you remember when i redefined the
notion of plus and p
i used this prover verifier
interaction the game between the pro
verifier
verifier where both of them were given
input x
and then the prover would send a proof
or a witness to the verifier
and the verifier will check if the proof
is valid given
the input x now
we can going to generalize this
definition this uh
gain between the program verifier to
allow two things
one we allow multiple rounds so
prover and the verifier proven verifier
will talk
for some polynomial in n number of
rounds by exchanging messages
the messages that the prover sends and
also the verifier sends
will have to be polynomially bounded
because the verifier is
going to be some polynomial time
algorithm it cannot possibly look at
very long messages given its restriction
on the runtime
so the prover has to send short messages
to the fairfire
same as was the case for the standard
classical definition of np that we saw
earlier
the failed fire in addition to
interaction the way fire is also allowed
to be
randomized now and here in this picture
is captured by saying okay
the verifier will be sending to prover
some random bit strings
each round so the challenges that the
verifier sends the approver
are encoded in random strings that one
z2 and so forth so you have an exchange
program send some y1
the verifier challenges by sending
random bit strings at one
the approver replies by sending some
message y2
the way fire challenges again and after
palm element rounds fairfire looks at
the whole transcript of the computation
on all the messages being exchanged and
must makes it
must make a decision to accept or reject
and the way we define the way fire's
decision it will be some
polynomial time algorithm capital v such
that
you apply this polynomial time algorithm
to the input x
and all the messages exchanged y1 z1 y2
z2 and so forth
note that even though v is deterministic
algorithm because
the verifier is using randomness random
messages that ones that so and so forth
this algorithm v is actually a
randomized polynomial time algorithm
if we think of randomness coming from
verifier's choices of the messages at
once
that t so we have interaction and
randomization and with this two
ingredients
we have a proof system which seemingly
which is seemingly more powerful than
the classical proof system for np where
we had only one round and the verifier
was deterministic polynomial time
algorithm no randomness used
so what does it mean to for a language
to be
in ip in the class ip we can define
the class ip and say that a language
l is in a class i p if there exists
if there exists a polynomial time
verifier v
such that for any for every input x
if x is in the language then there
exists a prover
that is able to convince the verifier to
accept with probability of one
or the probability over the the random
strings chosen by the verifier those
that's that i mentioned
and this is called completeness so if x
is in l then the verifier
can be made accept can be convinced to
accept
with probability one soundness
says that if x is not in a language then
no matter how clever how
devious the prover is
the verifier will accept with
probability bounded away from one
the probability over randomness is at
once at t that the verifier accepts
is going to be say less than one-third
so you have a gap
between completeness and soundness one
in one case and
at most one-third in the other case
so what i want to do next is give you
an algorithm or an ip protocol
for solving sharp sat
one small difficulty is that sharpshot
is not a language it's not a decision
problem
but it's very easy to fix using standard
tricks
so let's define the decision version of
sharpshot
denoted sharpshot sub d as follows
as as input you are given two things
a three cnf formula phi on variables x1
through xn
and the parameter k the number between
an integer number between zero and to
the n
which supposedly is the number of
satisfying assignments of the formula
phi
i need to decide if it is indeed the
case that
phi has k satisfying assignments
what we will show next is the following
beautiful result
of lund fort no carlos and nissan from
around 1990
that this problem sharps up decision
version
has interactive proofs
and we'll do that in a moment